[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and though kevin feige
tried to cast a memory spell to make us
forget all the scenes that we know are
gonna be in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness the memory still
remains throughout this video we'll be
going through all the leaks that line up
with the theatrical release the cameos
that the creative team have talked about
and the scenes that didn't make the
final cut we know from interviews with
both sam raimi and writer michael
waldron that there was 40 minutes cut
from the film and that the reshoots also
did some things differently to what we
got in the film full spoilers ahead for
what that was as well so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then i
highly recommend that you check out now
please hit the thumbs up button
otherwise i'll hate you in every
universe and don't forget to subscribe
for breakdowns from paul the dumbest man
alive watch your mouth now you might
remember last year that we did a big
video discussing the plot leaks for the
film and now that the movie's released
having gone back to these they were
pretty much 90 right with some major
inconsistencies and added scenes all the
cameos variants how they die and the
journey is there it's just different
details put in place for some parts that
you can go check out if you want now
just a disclaimer for this stuff in the
build up to a movie it's actually not
considered fair use to report on leaks
that you know to be true which is why a
lot of plot league videos tend to have
people saying this apparently happens
rumor has it and so on if you say that
things should be taken with a grain of
salt you're normally in the clear which
is why a lot of my videos that turn out
to be true still have this kind of
language in them now that the film is
out though i can say i know for definite
there was a scene with mordo in it in
which he went to visit wonder at the
start of the movie if you catch your
mind back to the end of doctor strange
then you'll remember that the
post-credits scene had him going on a
quest to kill the wizarding world worse
than fantastic beasts did in multiverse
of madness strange even mentions how
morta has been trying to kill him when
he meets the illuminati version but this
is something that we've never seen and
it's definitely not something that he
would really know about as mordo never
really said anything along those lines
at their last meeting now mordo was
going to be the main villain that showed
up in the introduction to the movie and
he'd be used to demonstrate wanda's new
ruthless attitude he would go to attack
her and she'd turn him into mom's
spaghetti beheading him within seconds
of his arrival it was going to be a big
way to start the film and it instantly
cemented wanda as the villain from here
we then jump to the gap junction which
is where we'd be introduced to america
chavez and defender strange seeing the
movie for myself i can definitely see
why they cut this introduction as i much
prefer learning the twist as doctor
strange discovers it i think it would
make the movie pretty clunky to have
this open it learn she's bad jump to the
gap junction then jump to the mcu then
have strange go to wonder to learn what
we found out 20 minutes before now this
also leaves mordo's fate out in the open
and interestingly both he and the a38
version are still alive mordo 838 is the
only surviving illuminati member and
perhaps they'll be doing something with
him in the future huge shout out to josh
from denim nerds for pointing that out
and it does leave a lot on the air for
the future of the franchise now when
wonder read the darkhold she picked up a
whole new set of skills to make her
dreamwalk however she could have sped
that whole thing up by checking out the
number one online hub for development
skillshare now being a youtuber it means
i've got to be equipped with a lot of
skills for the job i know a lot of you
punks think i just sit about watching
marvel movies all day which
is kind of true there are a lot of
things that i need to know to do this
this includes writing scripts doing
voice over work mixing audio editing
videos doing thumbnails and then
uploading the videos with all the best
seo terms to make stuff really stand out
in the search even social media is a big
part of the job and there's so many
things that you have to study in order
to be able to do this now that's why
skillshare is a perfect place for people
like me who want to develop everything
and its endless amount of courses have
massively helped out the channel there's
hundreds of experts on there like marcus
brownlee to lily singh and whatever
you're trying to learn this is the best
site in the world to activate your skill
set whether you just want to improve
what you're already doing or pivot to a
new career you can find fulfillment on
the website with all its amazing courses
the skillshare platform is now also
available in french spanish portuguese
and german or any language of your
choice skillshare is also ad-free so you
can stay in the zone whilst exploring
new skills new premium courses are
launched each and every week so every
day is like a school day that will help
you improve the first 1000 people to
head over to the link in the description
will also get one month free so
definitely go check it out right now
i've left my tracking link below in the
comments and huge thank you to everyone
who helps to support the channel whilst
helping to improve themselves much
appreciated and all the best
now tom cruise's iron man is probably
the biggest rumor that surrounded the
movie before its release fueled by the
ultron bots and the quick cut of captain
marvel many thought that this was in
fact him instead of lashonna lynch i
might have said mephisto was coming here
but at least i can die happy knowing
that i never said lashana lynch was tom
cruise anyway i'll let that go i've
taken enough out of that one i'm sorry
this is the last time now i actually
discussed this in a video and said how
i'd heard from multiple sources that he
wasn't going to be in the film but that
had also heard from some that i trusted
that he actually was it was all kind of
up in the air no one knew for definite
but michael waldron has discussed this
rumor with yahoo entertainment initially
he said tom cruise was indeed on the
cards for a cameo but that they couldn't
get him due to scheduling conflicts with
the mission impossible movies however he
did say that he was happy they got
hailey atwell who is also starring in
the upcoming mi films i have actually
heard there have been conversations
behind the scenes and that there are
plans to have crews appear in some form
as tony stark further down the line much
like john krasinski it's a fan casting
that people want and with waldron
admitting that he was brought up at one
point it could potentially be a
possibility in a feature film there were
also discussions like this with deadpool
and in an interview with comicbook.com
the screenwriter discussed how they did
talk about bringing in the merc with the
mouth however they realized that due to
the tone of the film that this wasn't
the right place to drop him in and
ultimately scrapped him faster than
obadiah stein knocks his tie out the way
many people of course thought they saw
deadpool on the poster for the movie but
they got you again you punk you damn
chump see ya chump
we also had a scene where we discovered
the 616 version of reed richards was
jimmy wu
now on top of this there was also
supposed to be an appearance by balder
the brave which i've seen certain
elements for in the illuminati scene we
of course saw that there were six chairs
and a space for professor rex balder was
originally supposed to be the seventh
member but this has now kind of been
brushed to the side with the empty chair
being chalked up to belonging to supreme
strange however mordo overtook his
position and this is because he wasn't
in the illuminati beforehand which is
why he didn't appear on titan along with
the rest of the group during the fight
with wonder balder was going to be
talked into ending his own life by the
witch but this was apparently taken out
so that the focus for this could be
given to black bolt again it's probably
the better way to do things and there's
already enough illuminati members as it
is so i can see why they removed things
for the final cut this is a similar
situation to captain marvel who was
originally supposed to appear at the end
of age of ultron they even filmed scenes
for this with a stand-in but they were
removed for the final cut now today
there was a report from deadline which
said that daniel craig was originally
supposed to be playing reed richards
however my sources told me about six
months ago that he was actually playing
ball of the brave and they sent some
photos of props across his evidence i
think craig is balder aka thor's brother
makes way more sense and recently when
stuff was cut my sources said they
couldn't understand why this was as he's
such a big name however apparently craig
dropping out was due to a spike in
pandemic cases so i think that's why he
was removed and also replaced olson
recently dropped an interview stating
that she'd never even met john krasinski
and i believe that he was someone
propped up in the reshoots which is why
his stuff looks a bit out of place
probably shot on a green screen and then
dropped in last minute in order to
replace craig who couldn't make it to
the film neymar two at one point was a
member for the group and we know that he
will be appearing in the upcoming black
panther wakanda forever film in the
comics he like professor x reed and
strange were all members of the
illuminati but neymar was cut for a
specific reason bike he apparently
wanted to save his introduction for the
upcoming black panther sequel and thus
they removed him early on in the
scripting process so that his debut
wouldn't be ruined now waldron also
discussed that dr nicodemus west was
gonna be in the illuminati universe as
well played by michael stillbog west
paul's from the comics and in those he
was a villain in the mcu west was the
one who operated on strange's hands
after the crash and he also appears in
the film at the wedding he definitely
blamed strange for robbing him of the
opportunity to say goodbye to his cat
and also his brother he seems to accept
that there was no other way but mocked
strange a bit by sarcastically saying he
was the best surgeon and the best
superhero stillborg's name even appeared
on the poster so it was pretty clear
that he might have had more of a major
role or that they were hiding the cameos
waldron stated that he worked at the
illuminati headquarters in 838 and that
he would mock strange during the lock-up
scene when wonder arrived to grab
america he would have been ripped apart
with the rest of the illuminati but this
death would have happened off-screen
waldron said that he died like samuel l
jackson in jurassic park and not like in
deep blue sea though we said that would
have been amazing now much like how
jackson's rey is killed off screen by a
velociraptor only for a body party show
up later on wes was going to be killed
by wonder and as christine in america
fled to an elevator the door would open
and his head would roll out of it pretty
gory and i would have loved to have seen
this scene but unfortunately it's now on
the cutting room floor along with west's
head now upon
and mordos to be fair now upon arriving
at comatose we get a whole host of new
characters including rintro and sarah
these aren't really expanded upon all
that much in the film and if you don't
know what comics they pulled from you'd
probably be like giant minotaur walking
around weird now there are funko pops
for them even though they probably get
about two minutes of screen time
combined that's because the pair had
much more expanded roles originally and
sorrow was actually teased at being a
love interest for wong we do somewhat
get a nod towards this as it seems like
the pair could be a bit close but any
romantic feelings between them is
completely skipped over i don't know if
it would have been too much of a
distraction to have it in the movie and
that we'd even have enough time to fully
flesh out the feelings that the pair
share it kind of also changes up the
dynamics for the ending of the movie as
wang says that he's pretty content with
the way things are he's somewhat happy
happy hogan in a way wait bad example
now raymie did say that there would be
three of the deleted scenes included in
the home release of the film and that he
knew what they were however he wouldn't
tell us i'm guessing that they're still
finalizing what to put out there what
would you like to have seen in the movie
should these scenes have been kept
comment below and let me know we are in
a competition right now and giving away
three copies of spider-man noway home on
the 15th of may and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the scenes
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of all the wtf questions
which will be linked on screen right now
we explain some of the big plot holes in
the film answer things like why the kids
are the same where vision is and so on
so
get yourself over there right after this
if not then thanks for sticking to the
video especially after this part which i
just ramble on a bit so
get the hell out of here you scumbag i
hate you three thousand take care of
yourself peace